now stepping out  drinking on the plane  Cory brand DUI caught on tape over a  million heads yeah doc is he all right  you've been suspended for eight weeks  was there alcohol involved in the  accident  the Grizzlies want proof that you're  attending a 12-step program well said I  want you out of sight until you've  completed eight weeks mr. brand has  kindly offered to stay here in Okmulgee  and take his brothers place as head  coach of the kids baseball team Emma  Johnson I'm actually one of the Bulldogs  other coaches Oh check this out  your mom boy band were the best couple  in high school you're pretty much just a  wild child fell into them but I've  changed Emma really  I found you a 12-step program and no  matter what you've done there will come  a desperation  do you now the  I need a miracle  walk away that's what you do best Cory  you will not say no no I'm staying I'm  talking about  you're a great mom  nothing great happens in the old back